доля Криму вона буде однозначно
визначатися на полі бою ми розуміємо що
за звільненням Криму суто військовим
шляхом будуть стояти великі жертви
багато вкидів різних є для того щоб
просто посварити між собою великі
українські народ і кримських татар не
можна змивати про Крим бо це не лише про
територію А це в першу чергу про людей
боротися треба за наш український Крим
бавовни в Криму деокупація півострова і
мобілізація кримчан на війну з Україною
про це і не тільки будемо говорити з
пані та мілою ташовою це постійна
представниця президента України в Криму
пані Таміла почнімо з актуального з
нещодавних подій минулої суботи 29
жовтня безпілотники атакували російські
кораблі у Севастопольській бухті ми
достеменно не знаємо хто стоїть за цією
атакою але так званий голова Севастополя
Михайло розважаєв сказав що це найбільша
Атака безпілотників за весь час війни як
у Криму сприймають цю безпрецедентну
подію Що ви можете сказати виходячи з
ваших контактів з місцевими активістами
свідомими громадянами як сприймаються в
Криму власне Варто сказати яким чином
реагувало окупаційні адміністрації або
так звана
Федеральна влада у Кремлі на цій події
тому що коли були вибухи на аеродромі в
Саках то Власне вони майже не
коментували цього те що ми бачимо зараз
що як тільки пролунали ці вибух у
Севастополі фактично були пошкоджені ці
кораблі морського флоту Російської
Федерації Вони одразу почали це
коментувати і для мене З чим це
пов'язано Да в першу чергу тому що
Російська Федерація намагається якимось
чином виправдати Ті дії які вона
здійснює зараз на території всієї
України всі масовані обстріли в тому
числі
використовуючи цей Фактор для виходу з
зернової угоди відповідно з цим
пов'язані всі пропагандистські наративи
які ми бачимо на території Криму да Що
це Україна якби обстрілює що Україна за
цими діями стоїть і відповідно
накручування
населення місцевого протягом 8 років
існував ключовий нератив чим
відрізняється Крим від так званого
Донбасу да Що там от війна от подивіться
що в Україні робиться Україна голодує
Україна не розвивається в нас тут регіон
ми захища на території Криму і так далі
протягом цих місяців великої війни після
24 лютого Вони все одно продовжували цей
наратив плакати Да що мова Захистимо І
власне він почав руйнуватися цей наратив
да Після перших вибухів усаках коли люди
почали реально задавати питання ми за
цим відслідковуємо за різного родуфорами
форумами або телеграм-чатами і так далі
Коли тому самому розважаємо задають
питання Скажіть будь ласка А де
бомбосховище А чому вони не підготовлені
От бачите що відбувається А що взагалі
відбувається Да і вони точно і відповіді
надають До речі бомбосховище не почали
будувати будувати не почали але почали
такі дуже показові інспекції робити
бомбосховище або там підвальних
приміщень і так далі показувати що от
бачите Ми там щось для вас готуємо але
затверджені місцевого населення
більшість місць які могли би бути
придатними для кінця
бомбосховища вони не були там підчищені
зроблені для людей Кирило буданов голова
Української розвідки нещодавно Минулого
тижня буквально заявив що Крим
звільнятимуть виключно військовим шляхом
і зможе це статися Вже наступного року
Як ви оцінюєте такі прогнози чи
поділяєте його думку
власне скажу наведу фразу яку президент
України Володимир Зеленський
неодноразово говорив да що ми не
поступимось жодним сантиметром нашої
землі Да і ми боремося за всі наші
території включно з Криму І цей шлях
який ми будемо обирати для звільнення
наших територій все буде наш шлях да
ніхто нам не може диктувати там якихось
вимог яким чином нам звільняти Минулого
року ми затвердили стратегію деокупації
реінтеграції ключовим напрямком в мене
часто про це питають ключовим
механізмом для деокупації
державної політики дипломатичний але але
якщо придивитися детально стратегію то
інші елементи використання інших
елементів в тому числі військового не
виключалися у цій стратегії власне доля
Криму вона буде однозначно визначатися
на полі бою те що буде відбуватися в
контрнаступальних діях по півню нашої
держави да загалом всій державі тому я
сприймаю абсолютно позитивно заяви
нашого головного фактичного розвідника
Кирила буданова який має безпосередньо
теж зв'язок з Кримським півостровом і
він тривалий час проживав на території
Криму тому видно що йому ця тема дуже
близька і він сам хоче потрапити на
територію Криму Але я думаю що це все ж
таки буде на суто військовий шлях А це
все ж таки буде якийсь гібридний такий
шлях повернення і знову ж таки президент
говорив неодноразово що ми розуміємо що
за звільненням Криму суто військовим шля
яким будуть стояти великі жертви скоріш
за все ми ж не маємо сумнівів що
Російська Федерація буде відходити дуже
спокійно Да не буде виходити відходити в
нас спокійно і буде прикриватися людьми
як живим щитом як вона це робить на
інших територіях які вже звільнені на
даний момент те що вони робили в 14-му
році на території Криму тому Звичайно що
будемо дивитися Але я думаю що скоріше
все це такі буде дуже гібридний шлях
повернення території До речі
щодо саміту першого міжнародного саміту
парламентського Кримської платформи він
Минулого тижня у загребі пройшов у
Хорватії там теж обговорювали деокупацію
Криму звісно і стратегію деокупації чи
побачили ви там підтримку ось такого
військового напіввійськового шляху
звільнення Криму ну власне це знаєте так
активне не обговорювалось що варто
сказати це саме перше які пройшов в
офлайн форматі І звісно що мірою там у
когось в промовах Це звучало я вже не
скажу точно у кого але ключовий Звичайно
що шлях і ну і платформа власне для
цього була створена і стратегії вона
вказана як ключовий інструмент
політико-дипломатичного вирішення
питання Криму тому ну було б дивне якби
розглядався і дуже активно розглядався
би варіант військового повернення Але
можливо не в промовах Можливо в кулуарах
там розмовах з тими ж представниками
парламенті в інших європейських держав
там Сполучених Штатів все-таки Ну є ж
зміна у ставленні до того що тут
відбувається і у підходах відповідно теж
має бути якась зміна ви не помітили її
ну власне більшість партнерів вони
говорили про те що розуміють що питання
Криму буде вирішено в будь-якому випадку
на полі бою на території України да
материкової частини України і те що
відбувалося на Харківському напрямку те
відбувається на херсонському південному
напрямку Тому ці процеси вони просто
пов'язані тому наші міжнародні партнери
розуміють що категоричних якихось
висловів щодо лише політика
дипломатичного шляху вирішення питання
Криму було б некоректне з їх боку якби
да це проговорювати тому більшість
партнерів особливо ті які дуже близькі
до нас Звісно що вони це розуміють вже
сміливіше проговорюють дасть ніж це
наприклад було минулого року на на
першому установчому саміті Кримської
платформи зараз часто в публічному
просторі лунають взагалі заяви про те що
можливо Україні варто відмовитись від
Криму віддати його Росії і піти на
переговори щоб уникнути жертв Ну
згадаємо того жилона маска Наприклад
таких настроїв ви не помічаєте у
міжнародній адженді на Кримській
платформі не помічали чесно скажу але
якби дуже важливо тут говорити все ж
цієї наполягати на нашій правоті України
да і варто в цьому контексті згадувати
що Російській Федерації заважає
використати тактичну ядерну зброю при
нашому контрнасипі наприклад на півдні
нашої держави або там на східних рубежах
нашої держави ключове що я побачила в
твітах Ілона маска Да що це не це не
питання навіть його
плану мирного врегулювання А питання
того що яким чином ці російські наративи
дуже глибоко проникли в розум дуже
розумної людини насправді Да і питання
того що буцімто Хрущов подарував Крим
Україні про те що там Крим - це
російська русская територия Але ж це
неправда там росіяни не було не можна
забувати про Крим бо це не лише про
територію А це в першу чергу про людей
які там проживають яких там переслідують
на території на території Кримського
півострова винищують цілі якби фактично
етноси та релігійні групи і так далі до
речі про людей окреме питання що буде Що
буде в Криму що буде на півострові після
деокупації і є вже пропозиції про давно
існують про автономію для кримських
татар у цієї ідеї є і прихильники і
противники які сперечаються між собою
противники говорять про те що це на
перспективу шлях до сепаратизму і це
дуже небезпечно оголошувати автономію за
національною ознакою для кримських татар
у Криму Як ви ставитеся до цього яка
ваша позиція в цьому питанні чи бути
автономії
в першу чергу слід сказати що дуже
багато питань після доокупації буде ми
вже як представництво національного офіс
Кримського платформи за дорученням
президента працюємо над рядом питань це
питання відповідальності Російської
Федерації тих хто там знаходяться на
території Криму вчиняв незаконні дії
воєнні злочини права людини порушив і
так далі це питання відповідальності і в
цьому контексті питання амністі
ілюстрації є питання пов'язані з
російськими громадянами які приїхали на
територію Криму
проживають не законно на території Криму
міста Севастополя від 500 до 800 тисяч
людей з різними експертними оцінками
знаходяться на території Криму в нас
єдина відповідь вони незаконно прибули
на територію Криму вони звичайно що
мають виїхати з території Криму потім
вже звертатися до офіційних органів
міграційних українських Да і оформлювати
посвідку на проживання якщо Україна
вирішить такі особі з числа російських
громадян надати таку посвідку на
проживання Вона може в законний порядок
її отримати щодо цих росіян якщо їх десь
500-800 тисяч Ну так званих понаїхавших
це якась зараз частка всього населення
Криму приблизно це це велика якщо
вважаєте що в Криму проживає
е-е два з половиною десь мільйони да
збільшилась тому що кількість людей на
території Криму нут рахується четверта
частина да це приблизно так відповідно
Звісно що вони будуть впливати і дуже
сильні якщо їх там залишити будуть дуже
сильно впливати на
етнічний склад конфігурацію Криму і на
всі подальші процеси тому що зрозуміло
що вони не будуть сприймати Україну а як
свою державу вони будуть завжди цією
п'ятою колоною яка буде заважати
розвиватися і це потенційна небезпека да
тому що Російська Федерація нікуди не
дінеться зрозуміла що вона будуть
хитатися населення бачення наше зараз ще
однозначно після деокупації буде
спочатку створена військова
адміністрація як перехідна адміністрація
Да потім міського цивільна адміністрація
і зрозуміло що дискусії і експертні і не
дуже експертні питання
територіальної автономії кримських татар
вона ведеться на перший рік складається
ключове що важливо сказати минулий рік
2021 був прийнятий закон про корінні
народу України які заклав власне
підвалини для підтримки і в тому числі в
питанні самовизначенні кримських татар в
межах Української держави однозначно
Зараз ми з українськійм урядовцями
експертами парламентарями працюємо Над
законом про статус кримськотатарського
народу і якби ми розуміємо що
питання автономії Звичайно що це дуже
складне питання зараз але ключове що в
будь-якому випадку зміни до конституції
вони не можуть прийматися у воєнний час
та під час війни Це пряма заборона
внесення змін до Конституції де війна Ми
не можемо говорити тому що тому прожев
вже про якісь ухвалення да а все решта
це питання дискусій правильних фахових
дискусій комунікації з різними
державними органами різними групами осіб
в тому числі з кримчанами якщо ви
запитаєте мою особисту позицію Я вважаю
не як представника президента
да звісно я вважаю що Кримські татари
мали би мати
національно-територіального автономію
тому що перше Російська Федерація дуже
активно намагається кримських тар власне
свої тенета затягнути да І це міг би
бути навпаки елементом стабільності для
України тому що кримські татар як
найбільш проукраїнська сила завжди була
за часів всієї Незалежності так якби і
зараз під час окупації після деокупації
могла би бути так Кримські татари завжди
говорили що зміни в статтю десяту розділ
10-й Конституції України Про автономну
Республіку Крим може розглядатися Але
лише у складі Української суверенної
держави і питання відділення
яка від'єднання від України не може йти
мова тобто є такий запобіжник якщо ми
говоримо саме про те що це автономія у
складі Української держави Української
держави і лише та інше питання що
маніпулятивні тези звучать про те що всі
права будуть віддані Кримським татарам
мені це теж Неправда а права будуть
абсолютно у всіх
на території півострову але якщо якісь
питання яке стосується суток римських
татар от банальний приклад
ще в за часів українського урядування
на території богородчасараї вирішили на
на території давніх святинь кримських
татар де поховані були святі Кримські
татари
прадіди Да там якісь захотіла побудувати
ринок і тоді це викликало хвилю дуже
незадоволені у кримських татар це
викликала якісь там погроми між собою
коли там вони були сперечатися і
відповідно всі питання які будуть
списатися суто кримських татар да їх
права прав культурних там релігійних і
так далі вони будуть потребувати
консультацій з кримськими татарами чи
можна тут побудувати
ринок на або там ще щось Кримські татари
могли б бути навпаки цим запобіжником
для різного роду
таких інших насправді сепаратистських
настроїв да на території півострову
запобіжником що територію Криму просто
так жити не можеш від'єднати Тому що це
є територія територія де сформовані
корінні народи і багато є думок що якби
в 14-му році
існувала би територіальна автономія
кримських татар то
ті корінні народи які там проживали да
вони би мали бути більш захищеними з
боку міжнародної спіль можливо реакція
могла би бути теж трошечки іншої
сильнішою аніж вона була в 14-му році
тому що Кримські татари корінний народ
взагалі корінні народи у світі захищають
по-особливому да мають особливий статус
і відповідно увага є набагато більше
тому що те що ми бачимо в такій Facebook
бульбашці де існує дуже багато
російських наративів насправді про це не
варто забувати що багато вкидів різних є
для того щоб просто посварити між собою
великі
українські Народ Да і якби одну зі
складових української політичної нації
кримських татар якби і ці дискусії які
ми бачимо Вони не є якби фаховому вони є
більше емоційними Я думаю що потрібно
приймати рішення дуже Зважені і по
відношенню до кримських Татарів взагалі
території Кримського півострова Я зараз
якраз висоникну тезу з цих не дуже
експертних як ви кажете дискусій Як би
ви відповіли на те на таку звичайно таке
запитання навіщо українцям воювати за
державність для кримських татар ну це
маніпулятивна що ж розумієте дуже
постановка тому що
Кримські татари воюють у складі збройних
сил України
далеко не про всіх можна розповідати але
знаю сотні кримських татар які воюють
боротися треба за наш український Крим і
Кримські татари є складовою української
політичної нації ніякої іншої і Кримські
татари які боролися весь період
української незалежності і навіть до за
власне цю українську незалежність які
були побратимами по сестрами числами
Чорновола
Стецько слави і так далі не можна
говорити що вони не є складовими
політичної української нації тому ми
спільно всі українські народ кримські
татар українці росіяни болгари греки
Азербайджані і так далі ми говоримо
зараз за нашу державу От і все Тому все
решта це маніпуляція це підігрування
ворогу лише лише ворогу водночас Росія
мобілізує активну кримських татар на
війну з Україною у саме Кримським
татарам масово роздавали повістки Ви
самі говорили що це ознака одна з ознак
геноциду фактично скільки кримських
татар призвали чи відомо до російської
армії де вони воюють питання роздачі
повісток і питання людини яка вже є з
мобілізованою це трошечки різні процеси
да тому що повістки роздавали дійсно
масово Кримським татарам не лише але ми
фіксували що велика кількість кримських
татар отримали ці повістки навіть після
отримання повістки Далеко не всі йшли
військкомати велика частина людей
виїжджали да і це теж трагедія в
будь-якому випадку чи то мобілізація
кримських татар чи то виїзд їх особливо
в країни Центральної Азії або Середньої
Азії пізніше говорили куди департовувала
в 44-му році кримських татар немає
точної кількості людей яка була з
мобілізована ці дані вони приховують але
наприклад знаємо що з Севастополя
мінімум 2000 солдат були відправлені на
територію Херсонської області і частина
з них є дійсно кримськими татарами Да не
так давно в одному з українських
видань був матеріал про те як кримських
татар або тікали від мобілізації або
кого призвали і вони говорили про те що
дами розуміємо що єдиним шляхом для нас
я здача в полон це достатньо складно
зараз зробити бо не близькі бої чому ми
не бачили протестів проти мобілізації в
Криму протестах активних не було на
території півострову який не було на
території
всієї Російської Федерації але дуже що
важливо сказати що
розумієте Крим - це територія без прав Я
протягом
восьми з половиною років да тобто коли в
Криму
нашпоговано просто не лише військовими а
спеціальними цими органами центр
продоводії екстремізму ФСБ і так далі
тому там в принципі будь-які протести
вони відкриті протести да вони неможливі
Хоча з іншого боку є протести проти
війни ми їх спостерігаємо слідкуємо
починаючи з лютого місяця з рядом
активістів ми спілкуємось комусь навіть
кримінальне переслідування є за те що
вони війну війну і назвали
розповсюджували якісь листівки і так
далі тому спротив Криму є І це неправда
що його там немає просто його вони цей
спротив має зовсім інші форми да хтось
розклеїв листівки хтось б'є А машини
символікою хтось ставить пісні на
кримськотатарському весіллі українські
директор да отримує не лише штрафи
навіть адміністративні арешти за це ми
лише знаємо майбутньому 150 випадків в
те що ми відслідкувала судових реєстр
окупаційних спочатку Спочатку
масштабного вторгнення Я думаю що таких
є більше тому що далеко не все вас
з'являється судових реєстр ось ви
згадали до речі про те що нещодавно якщо
не помиляюсь 21 жовтня в Алушті
українського громадянина засудили до
двох з половиною років в'язниці за те що
він нібито дискредитував армію РФ і це
перший кримінальний саме вирок за такими
звинуваченнями це означає що репресії
посилюються ми слідкували за цією
справою фактично з перших днів коли
дізналися про неї це Олександр терапон
який розповсюджував листівки антивоєнні
у галушці і в селах поблизу тому так
Звісно що репресії посилюються повторюсь
через те що є спротив а спротив
народився Чому Тому що люди почали
розуміти що їх діє до чогось можуть
призвести
Велика різниця 14 і 22-го року бо зараз
ми маємо сильну українську владу да які
довіряє велика кількість людей і маємо
сильні українські військо да маємо
волондерів в кінці лютого в березні
14-го року всього цього не було люди не
розуміли що і вірніше розуміли що за
ними не стоїть хтось і хто їх підтримає
Да у їх якби дій тому супер активного
спротиву Хоча він теж там був його не
було в 14-му році зараз Люди зрозуміли
що йде несправедлива війна велика війна
але і це певний шанс для того щоб
підтримати свою державу і шанс для
повернення контролю над Кримом да
повернення
Криму під контроль Української держави
Але повторюю ще раз це навіть не Москва
це не Пітер це не інші регіони
Російської Федерації Це Це набагато
гірше тому що територію нашпиговували
військовими спеціальними органами і так
далі це територія ФСБ да от просто
відповідно Це Це військова база велика і
так далі можемо багато поганих епітетів
називати да по відношенню до Криму всі
разом да зона без правил які називають
відповідно
публічного протесту ми і не очікували і
для мене самоє було абсолютно
здивуванням що такі люди як Саша та
рапун там ряд інших там Богдан з'їза
вони з'явились люди які весь цей час
Сиділи як ми Жартуємо всередині команди
тихо ненавиділи просто Росію весь цей
час вони не як твійстами ніякими взагалі
воно ніде не з'являлася ні на яких
акціях проте тексту навіть на акціях а
там підсудини ходили і так далі Це
просто вони вирішили що ні ми не згодні
з цим і наші державі потрібно Зараз саме
зараз підтримка дуже сподіваємося що
держава підтримує таких проукраїнських
людей Бо Крим це ж Україна тому Дякую
вам пані Таміла за цю розмову дякую вам